what do you feel about the
turing test as a as this modality to
distinguish
uh general artificial intelligences
well let's begin by asking what turing
thought about it so if you look back at
his
famous 1950 paper on machine
thinking he says the question whether
machines can think is too meaningless
to deserve discussion okay
that's what turing thought about it he
thought that the
imitation game as he called it could be
a useful device
for stimulating better
construction of machines of software and
so on
and i said it might in 50 years and just
modify the way we think about thinking
but it's a question where the machines
can think is too meaningless to deserve
discussion
it's kind of like asking whether
submarines can swim
you want to call that swimming okay they
can swim
uh in fact language is different in some
languages
airplanes fly and other languages they
glide
you know that's uninteresting
conventions
now it takes a turing test itself and go
back to the 17th century
the origins of modern science they had
something like the turing test
descartes asked the quest he was part of
this
galilean challenge it was galileo and
many others
descartes asked how can
a person carry out
the normal creative use of language
you know what to say in particular
circumstances
you're producing sentences constantly
which are novel you never heard before
nobody ever heard them before
but others can understand them they're
appropriate to situations
but they're not caused by situations you
could have said something else
so it's not as they put it you're
you're inclined to say certain things
but not
impelled and then
some of his followers jacques courtemoa
another cartesian
proposed test experimental tests
said suppose there's another creature
that looks like us
we want to find out if he has a mind
like ours
so we run experiments not to
ask him would he say the kind of thing
that's appropriate in particular
circumstances
that's the touring test but it was
different in the 17th century
there it was science for them remember
it's a question of existence
there's a mind which is a thing in the
world
there's a body which is a thing in the
world we want to know whether another
creature
has the mind it's like asking does he
have a liver
and it's asking a question of the
physical sciences
that's right or for the cartesians for
the gala lands
the analog of the turing test it's a
straight
scientific question for touring it's not
a scientific question
it's a way of stimulating your
imagination or something like that
so in a way the 17th century tests were
much more serious
you know your computer that tells you
something yeah that's fine
i mean if alexa helps you to think of
something who cares
but there's no science involved right
is that uh does that parlay with or you
know
dovetail with your well-known views on
the
elon musk's neuralink project it feels
so real
it feels very real but but it's
it's these are all uh impulses from
neurons
uh where you've said that you know
trying to
move your arm uh you know uh with a
neuro embedded chip like neurolink
is perhaps feasible at some point but to
find out what you're thinking
uh there seems to be you claimed in 2018
i believe
that there's no way to do that because
we don't understand how to proceed and i
think that
i don't think your views have changed
much right all right
we don't even know if we're looking at
the right thing how thinking may not
involve neural nets in fact there's
pretty good reason to believe that it
doesn't
uh neural nets for one thing or neural
transmission is pretty slow
as we were you know by the relevant
criteria
by the criteria of what we were talking
about before
how rapidly you think by that criterion
is known back to helmholtz in fact the
neural transmission is
pretty slow furthermore neural nets
don't have the right
the right architecture you have to
what we need is something like touring
architecture
something that has basically the control
unit of a touring machine
you know right dress you can't do that
in the walnuts
they just don't have the right
properties that's why
stuart hammer off what you mentioned
before is uh
looking at things like microtubules
the same as in the the internal
structure of the neuron
which has a vastly more computing power
roger prinrose is working on this main
work on it was done by
randy galliston record neuroscientists
done very interesting work arguing what
i just said i'm just quoting him
that the neural net systems are just the
wrong place to look
they don't have the kind of architecture
which is involved in thinking we have to
find
something else it might turn out to be
at the molecular level
with the level of rna you know molecular
level you're really getting
massive possibilities of computation so
maybe
just duplicating a neural net will tell
you nothing
because you're not looking in the right
place we don't know
i mean the thing to do is do the science
first and then
worry about the engineering
you